[CHOIR SINGING]
CHOIR: Ooh, ooh, ooh.
Ooh, ooh, ooh.
If my true love, she was
near me, she was near me,
I will never find another.
LARRY ARNN: I had
this introduction
of Professor Jackson worked
out for last time, when
he was scheduled to speak.
And when he couldn't come, RJ
Pestritto filled in for him
beautifully.
And he couldn't come
because Gina had given him
another baby, and they
were going to bring it home
from the hospital.
And he wouldn't miss that.
I guess he thought
Gina might drop it.
[LAUGHTER]
And my introduction
last time was
that I was going
to use the occasion
to settle the dispute
that Gina and I have.
Is Gina here?
She's going to come some time.
[LAUGHTER]
But her presence
is here in a way
that I'm about to
make known to you.
Because she and I have been
arguing for years what he looks
like.
She claims he looks like a hobo.
[LAUGHTER]
And I claim that he looks
like Rasputin, the mad monk.
[LAUGHTER]
Or else he looks like the
great uncle of Raymond Spiotta.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
But I have to recite his resume.
And the question
of his appearance
begins with the first award
this man has ever received,
which I'm now going
to show to you.
He was the calendar
boy for the Big Boy
Market in Modesto, California.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
And you can all
thank Gina for this.
[LAUGHTER]
And lest this should
ever be forgotten,
there are about 200
copies of this photograph
back there for any of you who
want them to take with them.
[LAUGHTER]
Because I think it important
for them to get around.
[LAUGHTER]
Justin Jackson is
a very unusual man.
He comes from Modesto,
see, calendar boy.
What does he do?
Medieval literature.
He knows Old and Middle English.
He probably knows
all the literature
we have from it nearly by heart.
He is this kind of a teacher.
He has broken down the
parts of the teaching art
into its component parts.
And he is beloved by
all of the students
to whom he so
consistently gives Cs.
[LAUGHTER]
I had the pleasure of a
two-hour conversation with him.
It probably wasn't
pleasurable to him,
but it was so much fun to me.
Because he pours
forth how to do it.
And he can state exactly what
he wants them to be able to do.
They must learn to
analyze literature.
And that means they must get
inside it and see what it means
and why it means that and how it
expresses the meaning of that.
And then they must,
having understood
that, that is to say,
learned to read that way,
they must be able
to present that
in an organized and clear
and concise piece of writing.
And that is such a difficult
thing to learn how to do.
And if you,
prospective students,
learn how to do that thing,
you will be a different person
than anything else
could make you into be.
And one of the few
best people I have ever
seen at the teaching
of how to do that thing
is our beloved Justin Jackson.
[APPLAUSE]
JUSTIN JACKSON: Thank you.
Congratulations, Jim--
much, much deserved.
You become responsible forever
for what you have tamed--
some thoughts on roses,
foxes, and friendship.
President Arnn, my wonderful,
beloved colleagues, students
and guests, I'm honored to
have been asked to speak
to you today at convocation.
And I say honored
and not delighted.
[LAUGHTER]
Not because he's
sitting to my right.
To be perfectly
honest, I'm really
ill-equipped to give
a talk like this.
I have not the
eloquence of Dr. Birzer,
the wit of Dr. Whalen, the
decency nor the grace of Dr.
Wyatt-Hayes nor the majestic,
sonorous voice of Dr. Conner.
[LAUGHTER]
I like to think I'm
as funny as Dr. Arnn.
[LAUGHTER]
LARRY ARNN: Funny looking.
JUSTIN JACKSON: But
those sorts of jokes
get you fired if you're not
the president of the college.
[LAUGHTER]
The birth of my son Simeon got
me out of the last address,
so I thought I was in the clear.
But obviously, I was wrong.
I've tried diligently all
week to get out of this.
I really, I have.
[LAUGHTER]
My whole family has been
wiped out and in bed
for the past week with
Strep, and running
103-degree temperatures.
I had hoped to be infected.
[LAUGHTER]
My daughters thought it rather
strange, though entertaining,
that I kept licking
their hands and faces--
[LAUGHTER]
--mumbling, give me those
germs, and dabbing my cheeks
with their used tissues.
[LAUGHTER]
Yesterday, I actually offered
Dr. [? Sundal ?] 10 bucks
to hit me with his car.
[LAUGHTER]
But he declined,
indicating that he
was worried about putting
a dent in his precious.
[LAUGHTER]
I thought that was rather sweet.
He's never called me
his precious before.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
Nevertheless, I am here.
And really, not only am I
honored to be here today,
I am happy, happy to be
here with my colleagues
and friends, of
course, but especially
happy to see you seniors.
I have grown close
to many of you
and have witnessed
your intellectual
and spiritual
maturation, and consider
myself fortunate for
having studied under you.
When I was asked to
give this address,
my first question to Dr.
Blackstock was simple.
What are we looking for
in this sort of talk?
Dr. Blackstock suggested
that I offer something
that would take us
away from the hustle
and bustle of our daily
activities, especially
at this hectic time of the
year, that perhaps I could
look to something uplifting.
But I imagine that the most
uplifting thing I could offer
would be simply to
point out the fact
that we are here in a moment
carved out for us already
from the hustle and bustle,
a place where we find
the friends with whom
we spend our time
and waste our time, the
professor, then the students,
from whom we all learn so much.
So here we are again
at the end of the year,
saying goodbye to
friends with whom
we've just become acquainted.
At freshman
convocation, Dr. Arnn
often reminds parents of
their bittersweet moment,
what they've waited, worked, and
hoped for for their children.
This new life at college,
this foray into adulthood,
has finally come to pass.
These parents have cultivated,
nourished their children,
and now they must give
them up, offer them
to us to continue this project.
These parents must
now say goodbye.
Today, many of us here
feel the same way.
We have come to know you
and to know ourselves
better because of you.
And now you must leave us.
And this makes me sad.
We humans are a
funny lot, aren't we?
There's something in
us that can't help
but to affirm and participate
in the goodness of life,
even when a participation in
that goodness, in that beauty,
will ultimately lead to sadness.
I often like to tell my
students about my daughter
Lydia and her first
exposure to death.
Her goldfish died.
I would like to say
that it was a sad day.
But Lydia didn't quite
get death at that point.
She slowly came
to the realization
that her fish wasn't going to
be swimming any longer, that she
would no longer have to feed
him because he was dead.
When we walked outside to
give her fish a proper burial,
she turned to me and asked,
Dada, if a fish dies,
does that mean birds die?
We don't have a bird.
She just likes birds.
[LAUGHTER]
Yes, sweetheart.
Birds die.
Do cats die?
I knew where this was going.
Yes, sweetheart, cats die.
Even Floyd?
This is our cat.
Yes.
And if Floyd dies, does
that mean Puck will die?
He's our dog with one eye.
[LAUGHTER]
You can see the clear
hierarchy of pets here.
[LAUGHTER]
Fish, bird, cat, dog.
Lydia's my budding
little Aristotelean.
Matilda, too, Dada?
This is our dog with two eyes.
[LAUGHTER]
Yes, sweetheart.
You're going to die, Dada?
Yes, sweetheart, Daddy will die.
And if you die, will Mommy die?
And I thought, hey, at least
I rate higher than the dogs.
[LAUGHTER]
Yes, sweetheart, Mommy will die.
And will I die, Dada?
See how much fun parenthood is.
Yes, sweetheart, you will die.
I tried to explain that, though
we die, we don't really die.
But this explanation
didn't really interest her.
Lydia looked down at the grass
as we walked, took a few more
steps, looked back and asked,
can I have another fish?
[LAUGHTER]
And with this single question,
the pronouncement of her desire
for the responsibility to
feed a goldfish, to name it,
to watch it swim, to watch
it die, and to bury it,
with all of this, my
three-year-old simultaneously
rejected the absurdity
and meaninglessness
of death and
suffering and affirmed
the beauty of God's creation,
affirmed and accepted
our vocation, indeed,
life itself, a life
of responsibility, and
with that responsibility,
a vulnerability.
For a brief moment,
a very brief moment,
she stood at the
crossroads of nihilism,
to see humans as simply
beings unto death,
that all is, in fact, vanity.
And she rejected it, and
wished to accept her role
as a person who needs to
be responsible for others,
a person who needs
to feed a fish.
The title of my talk, a line
taken from the book, The Little
Prince, "You Become
Responsible Forever for What
You Have Tamed," seemed
rather appropriate today.
As I look out into
the audience, I
see only an affirmation of
what it means to be human.
I see students for whom we
as faculty are responsible,
students who came
to this college
to have their minds
cultivated, their souls tamed.
And this is really true.
When you enrolled at Hillsdale
College, you asked to be tamed.
You came to our classes,
to our office hours,
and requested, please tame me.
And we are obliged happily.
To our guests here today,
a bearded, unkempt,
ogre-ish looking man, declaring
that we have tamed these
students must seem--
[LAUGHTER]
--must seem hubristic, at best,
and coldly despotic, at worst.
But here is the secret
so many of these students
and certainly, all of my
colleagues, have discovered.
In the act of taming
someone about whom we care,
we, too, become tamed.
The act of taming
implies not domination,
not some sort of
condescending didacticism,
but an act of responsibility,
of self-giving a vulnerability
for both parties.
And as much as we try
to help shape the minds
and souls of our students,
so are our minds and souls
shaped by them.
I'm willing to
argue that there is
an intellectual and spiritual
give-and-take going on
in office after office on
this campus on a daily basis.
A student comes to the office
of the professor with a paper,
her thoughts on
Aristotle and CS Lewis,
perhaps even her
deeply held beliefs,
a paper which contains, not
simply clever thoughts strung
together, not simply
footnotes to show she's read
the relevant literature,
but something
of the student's
essential being, something
invisible to the eye, but
something more real, more
palpable than the paper on which
the student has communicated
her thoughts.
She has learned in some
way how to think from us.
Having been tamed or
perhaps still being tamed--
aren't we all-- she offers
something back to us
when she hands us the paper,
not our thoughts regurgitated,
but our thoughts
appropriated, taken on
by her own experience,
her own thoughts,
and communicated back to
us through her own words.
She offers us something outside
of ourselves back to us,
a gift.
Perhaps she even offers her
very personhood back to us.
She tames us, for
she has actually been
responsible for us all along.
This is perhaps the
very secret many
of you now must
understand as you're
about to leave this campus--
to get a job, to get married,
and, horror of horrors,
to have children.
All of this time,
when you thought
you lived under the
thumb of your parents
as they tried to direct you
in your various endeavors,
be it by rules or
by finances, they
were trying to tame
your young spirit.
Well, you were right
in thinking this.
This is exactly what
they were trying to do.
They were taming
you, directing you.
But here's what
you may not know.
You've always had
the upper hand.
You were never the servant
in this relationship.
You were always the master.
You were being tamed,
but in doing so,
your parents offered
themselves as a gift to you.
And now it's your turn.
You are now the ones who must
go out and do the taming.
And yet, always remain
mindful that the first gesture
of taming, the first
true act of love,
is vulnerability, the
willingness to suffer,
a recognition that you,
too, will be tamed.
And this is what it
means to be human.
I hope everyone will
forgive me for this,
but today I'm going to read
from The Little Prince.
It's a wonderful
little children's book,
and seems apropos for today.
If you are interested in an
investigation of the ontology
of love as a phenomenological
occurrence that
ruptures the horizon
of Heideggerian being,
and opens up the infinitude
of a self-emptying, keynoitic,
hypostatic instantiation of
a theandric existence proper,
then this children's
book is for you.
[LAUGHTER]
But today, I simply
want to focus
on a scene when the Little
Prince encounters a fox
and learns a little
something about his love
for his rose back on his
home planet, Asteroid B 612.
I simply wish to
read this to you,
and will resist the urge,
perhaps for once in my life,
to comment on this
piece of literature.
"The Little Prince asked,
what does that mean, tame?
It is an act too often
neglected, said the Fox.
It means to establish ties.
To establish ties?
Just that, said the Fox.
To me, you are
still nothing more
than a little boy who is just
like 100,000 other little boys.
And I have no need of you.
And you, on your part,
have no need of me.
To you, I am nothing more than
a fox like 100,000 other foxes.
But if you tame me, then
we shall need each other.
To me, you will be
unique in all the world.
To you, I shall be
I am beginning to understand,
said the Little Prince.
There is a flower.
I think that she has tamed me.
The Fox gazed at the Little
Prince for a long time.
Please tame me, he said.
I want to very much, the
Little Prince replied.
But I have not much time.
I have friends to discover
and a great many things
to understand.
One only understands the things
that one tames, said the Fox.
Men have no more time
to understand anything.
They buy things already
made at the shops,
but there is no shop anywhere
where one can buy friendship.
And so men have no
friends anymore.
If you want a friend, tame me.
So the Little Prince
tamed the Fox.
And when the hour
of his departure
drew near, aah, said
the Fox, I shall cry.
It is your own fault,
said the Little Prince.
I never wished you
any sort of harm,
but you wanted me to tame you.
Yes, that is so, said the Fox.
But now you are going to
cry, said the Little Prince.
Yes, that is so, said the Fox.
Then it has done
you no good at all.
It has done me
good, said the Fox,
because the color
of the wheat fields.
And then he added, go
and look at the roses.
You will understand now."
I can't-- I'm sorry.
I can't read The Little
Prince without showing
you the pictures.
[LAUGHTER]
He took so long to draw them.
"That yours is unique
in all the world.
Then come back to
say goodbye to me,
and I will make you a
present of a secret.
The Little Prince went away
to look again at the roses.
You are not at all
like my rose, he said.
As yet, you are nothing.
No one has tamed you, and
you have tamed to no one.
You were like my Fox
when I first knew him.
He was only a Fox like
100,000 other foxes,
but I made him my friend.
And now he is unique
in all the world.
And the roses were
very much embarrassed.
You are beautiful, but
you're empty, he went on.
One could not die for you.
To be sure, an
ordinary passerby would
think that my rose
looked just like you,
the rose that belongs to me.
But in herself alone,
she is more important
than all the hundreds
of you other roses.
Because it is she
that I have watered.
Because it is she that I have
put under the glass globe.
sheltered behind the screen.
Because it is for
her that I have
killed the caterpillars,
except the two or three
that we saved to
become butterflies.
Because it is she
that I have listened
to when she grumbled or
boasted, or even sometimes
when she said nothing.
Because she is my rose.
And he went back
to meet the Fox.
Good-bye, he said.
Good-bye, said the Fox.
And now here is my secret,
a very simple secret.
It is only with the heart
that one can see rightly.
What is essential is
invisible to the eye.
invisible to the eye,
the Little Prince
repeated, so that he
would be sure to remember.
It is the time you have wasted
for your rose that makes
your rose so important.
It is the time I
have wasted for my
rose, said the Little
Prince, so that he
would be sure to remember.
Men have forgotten this
truth, said the Fox.
But you must not forget it.
You become responsible forever
for what you have tamed.
You are responsible
for your rose.
I am responsible for my rose,
the Little Prince repeated,
so that he would be
sure to remember."
And so, my dear seniors, I
want to thank you for the time
we have wasted together.
It has been a pleasure.
[APPLAUSE]